men built the world like they they do  all the hard jobs in society everything  that makes the infrastructure run I'm  not saying we don't need men that's not  my view at all but I just feel like this  is what this is like that term left over  I feel like the things you're saying and  the overall Reliance of men that's what  perpetuates that view because it makes  it seem like a woman literally can't  survive without a man and I feel like  you're linking that like one thing you  mentioned earlier you said that there's  a link between divorce rates when women  were able to get access to birth control  and I feel like in terms of marriage  like when you're when you're equating  marriage with that's when a woman's  gonna have kids she's gonna take some of  the man's income in that sense I feel  like I've lost my point now I